some of these beggars yeah there is no
doubt that the conflict in Syria is a
big driver for the increase in a rest if
we take a look just at the Syria related
issue in general Scotland Yard have
revealed at 700 British nationals mainly
young man but some women and even
children who have traveled out to Syria
in recent years I'm not just the benign
purposes these are people we suspect of
having other motives well many of course
that have gone out there see they're
going out to work for charities and
alike but Scotland Yard see absolutely
not many in fact the majority that are
going out are actually going to join up
with groups like Islamic state and lots
of concerns about these people returning
to the UK what do we know about that
well the figure for that is around half
about 350 of those who have gone out to
Syria are already back in the country
most have not been charged with any
crime simply because there isn't the
evidence to put before the court but
that doesn't mean according to the
police that they don't pose a threat
quite the opposite they see some will
pose a threat to the public and we have
seen an increase in related arrests as
well haven't yes quite a significant
increase 338 people arrested between
2014-2015 essentially last year that
compares with 250 for the previous year
so it's a rise of some thirty three
percent and fifty percent of the arrests
are related to Syria so you can see why
there's such pressure to have a counter
radicalization program here in the UK no
those are Syria related what about is
related well very interestingly we got
some figures through for a block of
three years the number of arrests are up
56% to terror related arrests over the
last three years and that's significant
because that period essentially is the
existence of Islamic states only been
around three years fifty fifty six
percent up on what the figure was the
previous three years really underlines
what the issue is mark thank you